to the Department of Justice has
released more details on the documents
seized from Mar-A-Lago as we're also
waiting for a decision on the special
Master to review the presidential
records here to break it all down Fox
News contributors Greg Jarrett and Sarah
Carter uh obviously we're all still
surprising we're heading into a holiday
weekend
fascinatingly this is what Joe Biden
decides to do as we lead into this thing
and now he's trying to walk it back but
this is coupled with a decline of his
popularity according to Reuters by seven
points after the Mar-A-Lago raid after
the uh the uh the school loan debacle
payback and now you've got this imagery
that we've got and this fight about the
special master so we're going to clearly
the as we you know been discussing the
judge wants to I think write out Greg
something decent to explain her decision
but why is the doj fighting this so so
badly when it would help us is all
respect the end result of what happens
here
because they're Above the Law and they
don't want to be fair or neutral or
objective
and you know it was incredibly and sadly
appropriate last night's hellish imagery
in front of Independence Hall it was
right out of Dante's Inferno and a
hieronymous Bosh painting but it
underscores that this is a President Who
if you dare to oppose him if you don't
like his policies but instead like
Republican policies or you vote for
Donald Trump which is basically half of
America
Joe Biden will use the FBI the
Department of Justice and soon the IRS
to come down on you like a ton of bricks
with the full force of the federal
government uh you know what we learned
in today's disclosure is they took
everything from Mar-A-Lago except the
chandeliers in the carpeting and they
took hundreds of personal items
newspapers books clothing for goodness
sakes
and it it simply proves that this was a
lawless search and seizure under the
Fourth Amendment but none of IT
addresses uh the real legal issues were
these so-called classified documents
actually Declassified and number two did
the president actually have under the
presidential records at a right of
access and custody of these documents
that's never been litigated under the
presidential records act that's how it
should have been handled in a civil
enforcement proceeding indeed not this
Lawless search and seizure yeah yeah
Sarah you know it's interesting because
while we're discussing if we can trust
the FBI and their intentions and the
intentions of the government and the
direct you know the Director of National
Intelligence and their little team teams
after that speech last night is there
any doubt that the government as an
entity is a problem
oh I I absolutely agree with you Tammy
it was like the lifting of a veil that's
what I talked about I remember looking
at the speech last night in just sheer
stunned horror and then thinking to
myself oh look he's actually exposing
himself and his entire Administration
this entire raid into Mar-A-Lago is
obviously political it's obviously a
continuation of what started way back in
2016. we can all we have to do is go
back to 2016 to realize every step of
the way how they targeted president
Trump and everyone around him from the
FBI using a Steele dossier that was paid
for by the Clinton you know by Hillary
Clinton and her attorneys in order to
spy on President Trump and then to spy
on Carter page a citizen of the United
States how they expanded their powers
and how now just as Greg is saying
they're expanding their powers to us the
people we saw saw that it was evidence
you know if it walks like a duck and it
looks like a duck it's usually a duck
and that's exactly what we're seeing now
with the Biden Administration and I
think every American should be very
concerned about how far this
Administration and how far the radical
left is willing to go because with the
hiring of 87 000 IRS agents and an FBI
that seems bent on a political
weaponization of its agency against an
opponent a political opponent our nation
is no longer living by its fundamental
principles yes and you know it's
completely living by something else we
have seen some hints of this certainly
with Lois Lerner and the IRS with you
know seeking of the of uh you know the
FBI on others throughout this process
for decades it seems like now they're
just not trying even trying to pretend
what the federal government has become
with the agencies with the right
leadership of course in Reformation as
we've done in the past we can get over
this Sarah Greg thank you all very much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else